As I said in the beginning, if you're going to run ads, you're just going to need to go
ahead and expect and accept the fact that you are going to have an ad suspension.
Okay?
And if you're watching this video just to watch this video and you haven't had one yet,
no problem.
It's totally fine.
I've had people that have seen people have ad suspensions and they ask, and it's a good
question.
They say, hey, what can I do?
What are the top two or three things I can do to avoid ad suspensions?
Okay?
My advice is don't worry about it.
Now don't do something stupid.
And if you see somebody comment on something, like try your best to avoid it.
But what I'm telling you right now is that it happens to everybody.
It really does.
For example, I have run a one point, at this point, time I'm recording this, $1.2 million
in ads.
Okay?
It took me four years to get an ad suspension.
Four.
Okay?
And I had actually spent over a million dollars.
And I was like, you know what?
I'm good.
I'm not going to get the suspension, whatever.
And I got four in one single day after spending a million dollars.
So Google doesn't, it's not a respecter of persons as they say in the Bible, right?
They don't care.
They don't care how much money you spend.
They don't care who you are.
They're going to suspend you at some point.
And here's my theory is Google, and you got to look at it from Google's perspective, right?
Google's a massive company.
We talked about this a little bit at the beginning.
They're trying to protect their own butts, okay?
You can't really blame them.
So I just want to say, number one, it's going to happen.
And so the first thing is, when this happens, I want you to, if you're watching this video
because you just got a suspension, take a deep breath, okay?
Breathe in, exhale, and realize you ain't special because everybody deals with them,
okay?
So just realize everyone dealt with them.
Up until this point, and at the time of recording, I know we have a couple students that are
currently under some suspensions, but I, to my knowledge, okay, again, to my knowledge,
at the time of recording, with how many students, I don't even know how many students we have
right now, but we have not had one student that's come into this program that has had
a suspension that we have not been able to find a solution for, okay?
And for the people that are in one right now that are going to watch this going on, oh,
that's me, I'm going to be the one, I promise you're not going to be the one.
You're not going to be the one because we haven't had that happen with anyone.
You are going to go through it, it's going to happen, and the way I look at it is two
ways.
Number one is once you get through it, I've seen that Google doesn't hit you again with
a suspension.
Typically, it's like they give you the suspension, you get through it, and they're like, okay,
that guy, that girl, she's good.
That's a real business because they appealed that many times.
No fake clown would do that.
They're good, we're going to let them through.
I haven't changed anything.
Since I had my suspensions and I appealed them and I got out, I haven't changed one thing.
I didn't learn my lesson, I didn't get slapped on the wrist and go, oh, I'm not going to
do this or that because Google doesn't even know what you did wrong.
You go ask their people, you get on a hold of their team, which is almost impossible,
they can't even tell you.
Take a deep breath, relax.
Everyone's been through it.
No one's not gotten through it.
There's always a solution.
I promise you that.
Let's talk about these suspensions just really briefly.
I want to talk about the two types of suspensions really, really quick.
Number one suspension is, well, it's not in any order, but what you're going to see more
often than not is the suspicious payment suspension, which happens to be a little bit more difficult
to unsuspend from, at least compared to the second suspension type, which is something
around circumvention.
They'll say, hey, you circumvented systems or circumvented this.
I don't even remember the verbiage, but they're going to tell you, you got some kind of circumvention.
Those are the two things.
Most people that are watching this, most people are going to have some kind of suspicious
payment suspension.
Guys, what you're going to do if you do have a suspension.
The game is really, you just want to make sure there's nothing weird.
Some of the things that when I say weird that I've seen is, let's say three years ago, and
if any of these trigger thoughts, oh yeah, yeah, that's me, go and fix these things.
I know we had a student that years and years ago, they had set up an ad really quickly
and they're like, oh crap, I forgot about it.
They went, they checked it out, and there was a balance of literally like $2, or maybe
it was even like 20 cents.
They went and they paid it, and then a couple days later, a couple appeals later, voila,
they're going.
That's one thing I've seen.
Other thing is, I've seen people, they've used weird cards.
They've had cards on multiple accounts.
What I would tell you with suspicious payments is we need to diagnose the problem.
If you have multiple accounts, go and check all of those.
Make sure there's no balances that are outstanding.
It might be something as dumb as 20 cents.
Who knows?
Then also, how many accounts, how many Google ad accounts is your card linked to?
I know that it seems like, again, I don't know, but it seems like that seems to be a
big factor.
What I want to tell you not to do, what I don't want you to do, the first thing is do
not go and create another ad account.
Do not go and create another ad account.
You think Google is that stupid.
They understand how people operate.
They know how people think.
That is not going to do anything.
Don't go and create another ad account.
All that you're going to do is you're going to try and make sure there's nothing else
that's weird out there, no extra accounts, no outstanding balances.
Ask yourself, what kind of a card am I using?
Am I using some weird one-off card, whatever, some prepaid visa, whatever it is.
I don't even think they would allow that.
Go and close all those things up.
What you're going to do is you're just going to go and you're going to fill out an appeal.
You're going to click on the button.
It's going to say, if you think this is wrong, click here, and I'm not going to show you
on the screen because it's going to change.
Go find that button, click it, and it's going to have this application, this appeal application.
Go and fill it out and fill it out as thoroughly as you possibly can.
As thoroughly as you possibly can without spending that much time.
You're going to go through it, you're going to hit submit or whatever the verbiage is
and you're going to send it off, and what's going to happen is it's going to be off with
Google for sometimes 24 hours, sometimes a couple days, sometimes I feel like it's
a week.
You're going to send it off and they're going to come back and most often the first time
they're going to say, we apologize for the inconvenience but your appeal request has
not been granted.
You're like, oh my gosh, the world's ending.
It's not.
What are you going to do?
You're going to go appeal again.
This time you're going to ask yourself, did I fill it out thoroughly?
If you didn't, damn it, fill it out thoroughly because you should have done that the first
time.
You're going to appeal and you're going to send it off.
Is there anything that you missed?
Any answers that you were half-assed that you could fill out better?
Go and appeal again.
You're just going to do this process and I know that you're going to be like, oh my gosh,
this sounds terrible.
It is.
It sucks.
You're going to do this process and I have seen, there's one student I can think of off
the top of my head, they did this seven times before finally Google's like, okay, you win.
Here you go.
You're good.
Until you've gone seven, eight, I would venture to say, until you've appealed 10 times and
you're still running into the same thing.
Keep appealing.
Now, if you're not doing anything and you have accounts that are out there and you haven't
checked to see if there's any weird stuff, then yeah, you might appeal forever, but as
long as you shut all that down and go and check that and go do a very thorough, what
would be the word?
You want to go and just make sure, an audit, a thorough audit of accounts that you may
have set up.
Try and think.
Was there a time when you watched a video in another group and they told you to go do
and you wouldn't set up this ad account and think like, what emails?
What I do is I go and search on my phone, I have all these emails linked up, I go and
search Google ads or payment successful and I look, oh, and I look at the email, it said
it too.
Oh, it looks like I had my ad account set up under that email and the reality is in
this business, we set up a lot of emails, we have a lot of burner emails, we have a
lot of accounts and it kind of sucks and if you're not good at organization, you can get
stuff kind of spread out, go and shut all that down and you're just going to appeal.
You're going to fill it out properly.
You're going to appeal.
And you will get unsuspended.
Now, obviously, as should be the case with any question, go and search the group, go
and look at the threads.
If those don't answer your questions, reach out to people, make your own post, tag the
people that have gone through it.
I know there's people that have gone through the freaking wringer and they figured out
a way to get out of it, but what I would tell you is this.
If you want to get out of the suspension, you will get out of it.
If literally a Google ad suspension is enough to throw you off, maybe you should consider
the fact that maybe you're not cut out for this.
I love the fact that there's ad suspensions because I know it's going to eliminate half,
if not 75% of the people that want to be successful and they're going to have an ad suspension.
As soon as they get it, they're done.
They're not going to try to do the ad suspension because it's too much work and they just don't
want to deal with it and they're just going to stick with ranking and waiting six months,
not me.
I'm going to figure it out.
I'm going to get to the bottom of it and I'm going to go.
That's with the suspicious payment.
With circumventing, it's the same exact process.
Click the appeal, fill it out, send it.
It seems to me in my experience and talking to students, if you have a circumventing issue,
it seems to get appealed a lot quicker because it's more cut and dry whereas suspicious payments
kind of out there, but guys, you're just going to appeal.
You're going to fill it out.
You're going to appeal after you've closed any doors that are weird, cards that are on
multiple accounts, et cetera.
Guys, once again, when you get a suspension, take a deep breath, exhale, realize you're
not special.
Everybody deals with them.
I deal with them.
You deal with them.
Every single person deals with them.
We're going to get through it.
We're going to keep appealing.
It doesn't matter if it's going to take 10 times, we're going to appeal and then once
we get on the other side of the appeal, we're back in action.